SENATE AND ASSEMBLY AGRICULTURE
COMMITTEES JOINT INFORMATIONAL
HEARING ON INITIATIVE STATUTE
NUMBER.
EIGHTEEN TWENTY THREE REGARDING
NEW STANDARDS FOR CONFINEMENT OF
CERTAIN FARM ANIMALS.
BAND SALE OF CERTAIN NON
COMPLYING PRODUCTS --
I AND MY NAME IS.
ON A COMPUTER IN THE ASSEMBLY
CHAIR ON AGRICULTURE AND WHY
LIKE TO WELCOME YOU TO THIS
JOINT.
JOINT HEARING --
PURSUANT TO SECTION NINETY
THIRTY FOUR OF THE ELECTIONS
CODE THE LEGISLATURE IS REQUIRED
TO HOLD PUBLIC JOINT
INFORMATIONAL HEARINGS ON
MEASURES THAT QUALIFY FOR THE
BALLOT.
TODAY'S HEARING SERVES TO MEET
THE STATUTORY REQUIREMENT.
I WOULD LIKE TO REMIND EVERYONE
IN ATTENDANCE TODAY THAT THE
COMMITTEE HEARING IS ONLY
INFORMATIONAL AND THIS COMMITTEE
HAS NO AUTHORITY OR POWER TO
MAKE CHANGES OF ANY KIND TO THE
PROPOSED PROPOSITION.
THE SUCCESSFUL PASSAGE OR
FAILURE OF THIS ISSUE RESTS IN
THE HANDS OF ALL CALIFORNIA
VOTERS.
THAT SAID I'M LOOKING FORWARD TO
AN INFORMATIVE DISCUSSION THAT
WILL EXAMINE THE CURRENT STATE
OF FARM ANIMAL CONFINEMENT.
IT IS MY INTENT THAT THIS
HEARING EXAMINE INFORMATION
NECESSARY TO BEST INFORM THE
PUBLIC OF THE INITIATIVES
CONTENT.
AND PROVIDE A FORUM FOR PUBLIC
DISCOURSE FOR THOSE OF YOU
INTERESTED IN TESTIFYING DURING
THE PUBLIC COMMENT PERIOD OF THE
HEARING.
PLEASE SIGN UP WITH THE
SERGEANTS BUT ALSO ASK THAT
PUBLIC COMMENT BE LIMITED TO ONE
MINUTE PER PERSON SO THAT SO
TODAY.
AND WE EXPECT --
AS SENATORS AND ASSEMBLY MEMBERS
TO COME IN AND OUT BOB BUT WE'RE
READY TO PROCEED TODAY SO --
IF WE COULD.
I'D LIKE TO ASK PANEL NUMBER ONE
WHICH IS OVER HERE BY THE
LEGISLATIVE ANALYST'S OFFICE
SHAUN MARTIN PRINCIPLE FISCAL
AND POLICY ANALYST WELCOME.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH FOR INVITING
ME HERE TODAY --
MY NAME'S SHAH MARTIN AND I WILL
BE SPEAKING FROM A HANDOUT
[inaudible]
AND AND SO FIRST I I'M GOING TO
GO OVER THE LA A ROLE IN THE
INITIATIVE PROCESS AND I'M GONNA
PROVIDE YOU WITH SOME BACKGROUND
INFORMATION RELATIVE TO THE
INITIATIVE.
THEN I'LL GO OVER THE PROPOSAL
AND BRIEFLY DESCRIBE OUR
ESTIMATE OF THE FISCAL A FAX SO
IF YOU TURN TO PAGE ONE IN YOUR
HANDOUT.
ON ARE ROLE IN THE INITIATIVE
PROCESS IS IS DIFFERENT THAN THE
ROLE THAT YOU TYPICALLY SEE AS
PLAY IN FRONT OF BUDGET SUB
COMMITTEES --
AND POLICY COMMITTEES WHERE WE
IN THOSE THOSE SETTINGS WE OFTEN
MAKE RECOMMENDATIONS.
WITH REGARD TO THE INITIATIVE
PROCESS STATE LAW REQUIRES ARE
OFFICE ALONG WITH THE DEPARTMENT
OF FINANCE --
TWO AN IMPARTIAL FISCAL ANALYSIS
OF EACH INITIATIVE.
AND THE LAW REQUIRES IS NOW
ASSESS. TO PROVIDE AN ESTIMATE
OF THE MEASURES FISCAL IMPACT ON
STATE LOCAL GOVERNMENT.
ON THE SUMMARY THE FISCAL IMPACT
IS INCLUDED ON PETITIONS THAT
ARE CIRCULATED FOR SIGNATURES
FOR THE INITIATIVE.
AND AFTER WE'VE BEEN.
COMPLETE THAT PROCESS BY TO AN
ANALYSIS OF THE MEASURE BY.
IT AN IMPARTIAL ANALYSIS HAVE
FOR THE STE AYE STATEWIDE BALLOT
PROPOSITIONS FOR THE STATEWIDE
VOTER INFORMATION GUIDE.
NOW SINCE INCLUDES A DESCRIPTION
THE MEASURE IN THE FISCAL FACTS
AND WE'RE CURRENTLY IN THE
PROCESS OF PREPARING THAT
ANALYSIS FOR INITIATIVES THAT
ARE QUALIFIED OR HAVE A
REASONABLE CHANCE OF QUALIFYING.
FOR THE TWO THOUSAND EIGHTEEN
BALLOT.
SO CONSISTENT WITH THEIR MANDATE
TO PROVIDE BY IMPARTIAL FISCAL
ANALYSIS OF STATEWIDE BALLOT
PROPOSITIONS TODAY I'M REALLY
LIMITING MY COMMENTS TO A
DESCRIPTION OF THE MEASURE AND
IT'S FISCAL A FAX.
SO IF YOU CAN TURN TO PAGE TWO
IN THE HANDOUT.
OUT WHERE WE GIVE SOME
BACKGROUND INFORMATION.
CALIFORNIA LEADS THE NATION IN
AGRICULTURAL PRODUCTION THAT
CALIFORNIA ALSO BUY SOME FOOD
FROM OTHER STATES INCLUDING MOST
OF THE EGGS AND PORK THAT
CALIFORNIANS HE'D.
COME RECENTLY THERE BINGO I'M
PUBLIC INTEREST IN FARM ANIMAL
PRODUCTION PRACTICES AND HOW
THESE PRACTICES AFFECT THE TRIP
BUT I TREATMENT OF ANIMALS.
AND VARIOUS ANIMAL FARMING
INDUSTRIES HAVE PRODUCED
GUIDELINES AND BEST PRACTICES
AND IMPROVING THE CARE AND
HANDLING OF FARM ANIMALS.
AND ALSO SOME MAJOR FOOD
RETAILERS HIGH AND RESTAURANT
CHAINS IN OTHER MAJOR FOOD
RELATED BUSINESSES HAVE
ANNOUNCED THAT THEY'RE MOVING
TOWARDS REQUIRING THEIR
SUPPLIERS TO PROVIDE.
THAT AYE ANIMALS WITH MORE SPACE
TO MOVE AROUND FOR EXAMPLE BY
ONLY PURCHASE SEEN --
EGGS FROM FARMERS TO USE CAGE
FREE.
HOUSING FOR HANDS.
A BIT OF BACKGROUND ON PREVIOUS
PROPOSITIONS PROPOSITION TWO
GENERALLY PROHIBITS CALIFORNIA.
THE FARMERS WHO HOUSING PREGNANT
PIGS CABS REYES REVEAL AND EGG
LAYING HANDS IN CAGES ARE CRATES
THAT DO NOT ALLOW THEM TO TURN
AROUND FREELY.
LIE DOWN STAND UP AND FULLY
EXTEND THEIR LIMBS AND UNDER
PROPOSITION TO ANY PERSON WHO
VIOLATES THE LAW IS GUILTY OF
THE MISDEMEANOR --
FOLLOWING UP ON PROPOSITION TWO
THE LEGISLATURE PASSED A LAW.
ADD THAT MADE IT ILLEGAL FOR
BUSINESSES WHEN YOU TO SELL EGGS
INCLUDING OUT OF STATE FARMS.
THAT PRODUCE FROM HANDS HOUSE
WAYS TO JOHN NEAT PROPOSITION
CHOOSE EGG LAYING.
SKY STANDARDS FOR EGG LAYING
HENS AND NOW IF YOU'LL TURN TO
PAGE FOUR IN THE HANDOUT.
I MEAN TO GO OVER THE WHAT
[inaudible]
OZELL.
I THIS INITIATIVE.
BUT THE REQUIREMENTS WOULD BE
PHASED IN FOR THE TAX OVER THE
NEXT SEVERAL YEARS IN INCREMENTS
ARE REGARDING THE MINIMUM SIZE
OF HOUSING HE'S FOR EGG LAYING
HANDS.
BREEDING PIGS AND COWS REYES
TRIVIA.
THAT REQUIREMENTS GENERALLY
SPECIFIED THE MINIMUM AMOUNT OF
FLOOR SPACE THAT MUST BE
PROVIDED TO EACH EGG LAYING HEN.
A BREEDING PIG OR CAFES FOR VEAL
IN TERMS OF SQUARE INCHES OR
SQUARE FEET.
THE MEASURE WOULD MAKE IT
ILLEGAL FOR BUSINESSES IN
CALIFORNIA TO SELL EGGS PORK
REVEAL THAT WERE PRODUCED FROM
ANIMALS HOUSE YOU MIGHT.
NOT MEET THE MEASURES
REQUIREMENTS THAT SELLS BEEN
APPLIES TO PRODUCTS FROM
CALIFORNIA AND OUT OF STATE.
A VIOLATION OF THE PROPOSITION
WOULD BE A MISDEMEANOR.
AND THE CALIFORNIA DEPARTMENT OF
FOOD AND AGRICULTURE AND THE
CALIFORNIA DEPARTMENT OF PUBLIC
HOUSE ARE REQUIRED UNDER THE
MEASURE TO PROMULGATE
REGULATIONS TO IMPLEMENT THE
PROPOSITION.
AND NOW TURNING TO PAGE FIVE I'M
GONNA CONCLUDE BY GOING OVER THE
FISCAL A FAX --
COMPARED TO CURRENT PRACTICE
USED BY SOME FARMERS.
THE PROPOSITION REQUIRE MORE
SPACE AND ALSO ALTERNATE METHODS
OF HOUSING FOR BREEDING PIGS
CABS REYES REVEALING A GLENN
HANDS.
POTENTIALLY RESULTING IN HIGHER
PRODUCTION COSTS TO THE EXTENT
THAT THESE HIGHER PRODUCTION
COSTS BECAUSE SOME FARMERS TO
EXIT THE BUSINESS OR OTHERWISE
REDUCE THEIR OVERALL PRODUCTION
AND PROFITABILITY THERE COULD BE
REDUCE STATE AND LOCAL TAX
REVENUES.
THE POTENTIAL DECREASE IN STATE%
AND LOCAL TAX REVENUES FROM FIVE
BUSINESSES IS LIKELY NOT TO
EXCEED THE LOW MILLIONS OF
DOLLARS ANNUALLY.
I'M AN AND OTHER POTENTIAL
FISCAL FACTS --
STATE COST RANGING UP TO TEN
MILLION DOLLARS ANNUALLY TO
ENFORCE THE MEASURE.
THAT DEPARTMENT OF FOOD AND
AGRICULTURE WOULD LIKELY REQUIRE
ADDITIONAL RESOURCES TO ENFORCE
THAT PROVISIONS.
OF THE PROPOSITION THAT
ESTABLISH REQUIRE.
OF HOUSING USE FOR EGG LAYING
HENS ARE BREEDING PIGS AND CATS
REST RUBIO.
AND MAKE IT ILLEGAL FOR
BUSINESSES IN CALIFORNIA TO SELL
EGGS PARKER VEAL THAT WERE
PRODUCED FROM ANIMALS HOUSE IN
WAYS THAT DO NOT MEET THE
MEASURES REQUIREMENTS.
SO THAT CONCLUDES MY OF REVIEW
FOR THE DAY I'D BE HAPPY TO
ANSWER ANY QUESTIONS YOU HAVE.
QUESTIONS OF MISTER MARTIN.
I HAVE I HAVE ONE QUESTION AND
THAT -- AT
AGE.
THEIR REPORT YOUR REPORT
INDICATES THAT --
FEE.
AND I WAS LOOKING FOR THE EXACT --
THAT MOST OF THE EGGS AND PORK
THE CALIFORNIANS EAT.
ARE PRODUCED IN OTHER STATES.
SO FOR TALKING ABOUT IMAGE DUMP
A MAJORITY ARE MOST OF THE EGGS
AND PORK --
IT IN AND THAT PROJECT ENDS UP.
IT IF THIS PROPOSITION PASSES IN
THE PRODUCT AND JEFF.
IN CALIFORNIA HOW WOULD CALLASPO
WOULD OUR REGULATORY.
AGENCIES DETERMINE THAT THE THAT
THE PRODUCT QUIZ.
WAS GROWN PURSUANT TO OUR RULES
AND REGULATIONS AS OPPOSED TO
ANY OTHER STATE TO RULES AND
REGULATIONS.
SO THAT'S WERE THE ARE ESTIMATE
OF COSTS THAT RANGING UP TO TEN
MILLION DOLLARS FOR THE
CALIFORNIA DEPARTMENT OF FOOD
AND AGRICULTURE COME IN.
AND WE HAD DISCUSSIONS WITH THAT
DEPARTMENT REGARDING THAT WHAT
THEY WOULD NEED TO PUT IN PLACE
IN ORDER TO ENFORCE THE MEASURE.
AND THEY AYE SAID THAT THEY
WOULD NEED TO HAVE --
A SYSTEM IN PLACE POTENTIALLY A
LICENSING OR REGISTRATION SYSTEM
FOR OUT OF STATE PROVIDERS.
ARAB OR AYE AYE STATE FARMERS
WHO PROVIDE THESE PRODUCTS O
CALIFORNIA SAID THAT THEY WOULD
ACTUALLY BE ABLE TO VERIFY THAT
THAT PRODUCTS CAME FROM SOURCES
THAT MEET THE PROPOSITIONS
REQUIREMENTS.
AND THAT IN THE PROPOSITIONS
REQUIREMENTS BOUGHT SAY THAT ANY
SALE.
PRODUCT.
SO --
THEORETICALLY IF PEOPLE LEFT THE
STATE TO BUY NON --
THAT PRODUCTS FOR THEIR OWN USE --
THEY COULD PURCHASE IT FROM ANY
ANYONE OUT A STATE AND BRING IT
AND FOR THEIR OWN USE BUT NOT
[inaudible]
PURCHASE.
BUT BUT IT REGULATES THE
PURCHASE UP PRODUCT BY
CALIFORNIA --
RETAILERS I GUESS IS THE POINT
THE POINT I'M TRYING TO GET TO
IS THAT THIS IS GOING TO
INCREASE THE COST FOR EVERYONE --
IN THE STATE AS WELL AS A CD IF
A TO ACTUALLY DO THE REGULATION.
THIS DATE IT WILL CHO INCREASE
COSTS FOR AND THE CALIFORNIA
DEPARTMENT IF IT NEVER CULTURE.
TO DO THAT REGULATE.
THE INDUSTRY AND MAKE SURE THAT
IT'S COMPLYING WITH WITH THESE
REQUIREMENTS BUT IT WOULD ALSO
INCREASE THE COSTS FOR CONSUMERS --
DICE.
THINKING THAT DIE WHO WERE STILL
WORKING ON OUR BALLOT CAMPAIGN
WHERE GOING TO BE VERY CAREFUL
ABOUT AND NOT.
GOING BEYOND WHAT WE'VE ALREADY
SAID IN THAT AND THEIR TITLE AND
SUMMARY AT THIS POINT
[inaudible]
OKAY [inaudible]
OKAY QUESTIONS [inaudible]
SO [inaudible]
AUTHORED.
GET INTO THAT PORTION OF THE
CONVERSATION.
IT I I'M GONNA MAKE SURE I'M
UNDERSTANDING TO THIS WOULD
ALLOW CALIFORNIA FOOD IN A BAG.
TO LICENSE OUT OF STATE
FARMERS XIN.TO SELL PRODUCT
WITHIN THE STATE.
WE I A IN THE MEASURE DOESN'T
SPECIFICALLY SPEAK TO HOW THE
CALIFORNIA DEPARTMENT OF FOOD
AND AGRICULTURE WOULD ENFORCE
THE MEASURE WITH REGARDS TO OUT
OF STATE FARMERS.
BUT IN DISCUSSIONS WITH THE
CALIFORNIA DEPARTMENT OF FOOD
NOW THE CULTURE THAT WE HAD WHEN
WE CAME UP WITH THIS ESTIMATE OF
THEIR COSTS.
THEY INDICATED TO US THAT
THEY'VE DONE THIS TYPE OF
ACTIVITY IN THE PAST AND THAT
THEY ARE ESTIMATED THAT THEY
WOULD NEED ADDITIONAL STAFF
ADDITIONAL INFORMATION
TECHNOLOGY RESOURCES.
AND POTENTIALLY NEW RESOURCES
FOR THEIR BORDER INSPECTION
STATIONS.
IN ORDER TO ENFORCE THE MEASURE.
OKAY IN AND DO YOU HAVE THE
NUMBER ON FOR FURTHER ON THE
SIGNATURE COUNT ON HOW MANY WERE
PAID VERSES ON PAID. ONE THE
SIGNATURE GATHERING I I DON'T
HAVE THAT INFORMATION AND LOVE
KNOW THAT NUMBER.
OTHER QUESTIONS YES MISS AG
WORKER YEAH THANK YOU VERY MUCH
FOR THE INFORMATION SO I COUPLE
THINGS IS THAT.
I'M A SENIOR ESTIMATE OF COSTS
ARE OPPORTUNITY COST INCLUDED
SUCH AS IF WE HAD BUSINESSES
LEAVE THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA OR
STAY IN THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA --
I'M CONCERNED ABOUT MENTALLY TO
THE CONSUMER.
BECAUSE IT WILL BE PASSED ON TO
THEM SO. FOR INSTANCE I DON'T
KNOW IF YOU HAVE ANY DATA OR YOU
WILL BE PUTTING ANYTHING IN YOUR
ANALYSIS IS THE FACT THAT --
WE ARE NOW LOOKING AT ARE WILL
USE THE CHICKENS FOR EGGS AT IT
FOR THE DISCUSSION.
LARGER CAGES.
LARGER BARNES TO ACCOMMODATE
AMID ALL THOSE KINDS OF THINGS
THAT ARE NOT FACTORED IN THE
WHERE.
ARE WE AT WE HAVE THE FACTORED
ANYWHERE AT ALL FOR THE COST
ULTIMATELY TO THE CONSUMER.
BECAUSE THIS PARTICULAR CHICKEN
MANY OF MY PEOPLE EAT AS THE
PRICE GOES UP.
YOU KNOW WE WANNA MAKE SURE ONCE
FED BUT THE PRICE IS GOING TO GO
UP.
SO -- I'M
JUST INTERESTED IN THAT WAS
FACTORED INTO ANY OF YOUR
NUMBERS [inaudible]
AND WELL WE DID TAKE INTO
ACCOUNT THAT POTENTIALLY.
FARMERS IN CALIFORNIA COULD
CHOOSE TO REDUCE THEIR THEIR
RENO.
YEAH I'VE THEIR OPERATIONS IN
THIS WOULD HAVE AN EFFECT ON
STATE LOCAL AND TAX REVENUES.
I'M WITH REGARD TO THE QUESTION
YOU'RE ASKING ME ABOUT --
INCREASED COST TO THE CONSUMER
AS I SAID BEFORE THIS PANEL IF
FAIRLY LIMITED TO SPEAKING TO
JUSTIN ALICE'S THAT WE'VE DONE
SO FAR. FOR OUR FOR THE TITLE --
BUT THAT MEASURE DOES REQUIRE
THAT BOTH OUT OF STATE AND IN
STATE.
FARMERS COTTON MEET THESE
PRODUCTION COSTS SO --
SOMEONE IF YOU WHETHER YOUR
BRAIN THAT THE PORK THE ACHES
CALM THE VEAL IN FROM OUT OF
STATE OR IT'S BEEN PRODUCED
HEARING CALIFORNIA.
ALL THE FARMERS WOULD HAVE TO
MEET THE SAME STANDARDS THROUGH
ASKING OTHER STATES TO MEET THE
CALIFORNIA STANDARDS.
IF THEY WANT TO SELL EITHER IF
THOSE FARMERS WANT.
TO SELL THEIR PRODUCTS IN
CALIFORNIA YES [inaudible]
THANK YOU.
SELECT.
WHAT WE KNOW IS THAT A MAJORITY
OF THE VEAL AND THE EXIT COMING
TO CALIFORNIA KEY CONSUMER
CALIFORNIANS ARE PRODUCED I'M
STATE?
SO I AM YES WERE ASKING THEM IF
THEY WANT TO SELL IN OUR STATE.
TO MEET THE REQUIREMENTS OF THIS
PROPOSITION IF IT PASSES ON AND
MY CONCERN IS THAT WE ALREADY
HAVE INCREASED --
AT REQUIREMENTS ON EGGS AND I'VE
SEEN.
THE DIFFERENCE WHEN I TRAVEL TO
OTHER STATES AND THEIR SOMETIMES
AS MUCH AS HALF OF THE COST NO
QUESTION THAT IT.
THAT IT'S IT'S GOOD FOR THE
ANIMALS I'M JUST TALKING ABOUT
THE ECONOMICS OF IT RIGHT NOW
[inaudible]
MR MATHIS.
BUT I'M JUST.
THIS IS GOING TO GO AFTER.
FOLKS IN AGRICULTURE WHO WHO ARE
RAISING.
THESE ANIMALS BUT I MEAN.
ON ON A CONSUMER BASIS WHAT'S
GONNA STOP.
DO YOU KNOW SOMEBODY FROM GOING
ONLINE WERE ORDERING A STEAK
FROM A MAGAZINE OR SOMETHING
LIKE THAT.
I MEAN IT'S THE THESE THINGS
HAPPEN ON A REGULAR BASIS I MEAN
PEOPLE NOWADAYS ARE ORDERING
FRESH FOOD OFF A AMAZON.
SO MAIN HOUSE FOOD NAG AND WITH
THAT WITH THAT INCREASE OF TEN
MILLION DOLLAR BUDGET I KNOW BUT
WHAT DO YOU FOR SEE THEM BEING
ABLE.
TO THE ONE THAT I'M GOING TO
REGULATETHE INTERNET IN AND
WATCH EVERY SINGLE BY AND EVERY.
MAIL ORDER.
STEEP THAT GOES THROUGH IT I
MEAN IT I I DON'T SEE THE
PRACTICALITY IN DOING THAT I
THINK WE'RE JUST WASTING MONEY
TO TO REGULATE.
SOME AND THIS CAN BE DONE
REGARDLESS.
BUT IT ACT TRIP FROM A
REGULATION STAFF ON HOW ARE THEY
GONNA DO THAT.
AND YOU KNOW IT WHEN WE TALK TO
THE DEPARTMENT OF AGRICULTURE
THERE ARE ANY THEIR SON A
FIGURING OUT HOW THEY'RE GOING
TO ENFORCE THIS MEASURE AND I
THINK.
THEY TO WERE PONDERING ON A
NUMBER OF ISSUES LIKE THE ONE
THAT YOU JUST RAISED AND HOW
THEY COULDN'T EFFECTIVELY.
ENFORCE.
I AGAINST THAT SOME OF THE TYPES
OF ISSUES THAT YOU JUST RAISED.
ANY LAWS THAT ARE ON THE BOOKS
THAT I HAVE TROUBLE WITH
ENFORCEMENT SO I DON'T.
HARD HARD TO SAY THE SKI BEHIND
ANOTHER.
ONE WELL THE OTHER ISSUE
OBVIOUSLY IS THAT WERE WERE
BEING.
SUIT RIGHT NOW BY OTHER STATES.
ON THIS TICKET A VERY ISSUE THAT
WE'RE TALKING ABOUT WHICH IS CN
WE REGULATE THEIR BUSINESSES.
ARE THERE BUSINESS PRACTICES
THROUGH OUR OWN REGULATORY
PROCESS SO OBVIOUSLY THAT'S
PROBABLY SOMETHING THE COURT AND
HAVE TO DECIDE IN TERMS OF A
CONSTITUTIONAL.
A ISSUES BUT DOWN.
ARE THERE ANY QUESTIONS. FOR
THIS GENTLEMAN IFNOT WE'LL MOVE
ON TO OUR SECOND PANEL.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH APPRECIATE
YOUR AT OVERVIEW PANEL NUMBER
TWO IS CRYSTAL MARLON FROM THE
HUMANE SOCIETY OF THE UNITED
STATES [inaudible]
WELCOME [inaudible]
AND THE PHONE.
GOOD MORNING MADAM CHAIR AND
MEMBERS THINK YOU FOR ALLOWING
ME TO TESTIFY IN FRONT OF THE
THE COMMITTEE ABOUT THE
IMPORTANCE OF PREVENT CRUELTY I
TO FARM ANIMALS ACT.
IN TWO THOUSAND ANY CALIFORNIA
VOTERS OVERWHELMINGLY APPROVED
PROPOSITION TWO WITH NEARLY 64%
OF THE VOTE ESTABLISHING THAT
HENS.
PIGS AND CAST STATEWIDE MUST BE
ABLE TO STAND APPLY TURN AROUND
AND EXTEND THEIR LIMBS WITH AN
EFFECTIVE DATE OF TWENTY FIFTEEN
TWO YEARS LATER AND TWENTY TEN
THE CALIFORNIA LEGISLATURE.
ENACTED EP FOURTEEN THIRTY SEVEN
TO APPLY PROP TWO STANDARDS TO
EXALT STATEWIDE.
REGARD THIS WHERE THEY ARE
PRODUCED.
ALTHOUGH MANY PRODUCERS INVESTED
TO CONVERT KEY TREE AFTER THE
PASSAGE OF PROP TWO TO PROPERLY
BE AND LEGAL COMPLIANCE.
OTHERS PUSHED FOR A DISINGENUOUS
INTERPRETATION OF THE LAW TO
KEEP HANDS IN CAGES.
FURTHER MORE THAN A DECADE SINCE
THE PASSAGE OF PROPOSITION.
TO THE MARKETPLACE AND STATES
SUCH AS MASSACHUSETTS HAVE
ADOPTED EVEN STRONGER FOOD
SAFETY AND ANIMAL WELFARE
REQUIREMENTS.
THE MEASURE WILL SIMPLY ENSURE
THAT CALIFORNIA ISN'T LAGGING
BEHIND.
THE ONLY LEGAL MEANS TO MODIFY
PROP TWO IS VIA A BALLOT
INITIATIVE WHICH THE PROPOSED
PREVENTION TO CRUELTY. TO FARMED
ANIMALS ACT PROPERLY DOES.
THIS MEASURE WOULD UPGRADE
CURRENT ANIMAL CRUELTY AND FOOD
SAFETY LAWS TO ENSURE THAT CABS
RATES REVEAL.
I CLING CHICKENS AND BREEDING
PIGS ARE GIVEN MORE SPACE
INCLUDING CAGE FREE CONDITIONS.
IT WOULD ALSO ENSURE THAT VEAL
EGGS AND PORK SOLD IN THE CITY
MEET THIS MODEST ANIMAL WELFARE
AND FOOD SAFETY REQUIREMENTS.
MORE THAN SIX HUNDRED AND SIXTY
THOUSAND CALIFORNIA VOTERS HAVE
SIGNED THE PETITION IN ORDER TO
QUALIFY THIS MEASURE.
THE INITIATIVE IS BACKED BY A
LARGE COALITION OF LEADING
NATIONAL AND STATE ANIMAL
PROTECTION NONPROFITS.
FOOD SAFETY AND CONSUMER
ORGANIZATIONS AS WELL S
HUNDREDS OF THAT.
CALIFORNIA VETERINARIANS.
KEY EGG PRODUCERS ARE ALSO
BACKING THAT'S THE MEASURE OF
RECOGNIZING THAT GOOD BUSINESS
AND BETTER TREATMENT OF ANIMALS
ARE IN ALIGNMENT.
SINCE THE PASSAGE OF PROP TWO
THREE HUNDRED MAJOR FOOD
RETAILERS HAVE COMMITTED TO FEES
AND KEY TREE PURCHASING
PRACTICES.
BUT ITS MOVEMENTS OF 90% OF THE
FOOD RETAIL SECTOR DEMONSTRATES
OUR IDEAS ARE SOLIDLY IN THE
MAINSTREAM AND PRACTICAL FORM.
OF FOOD PROCUREMENT AND SALE
PERSPECTIVES.
WE RECOGNIZE THE TRANSITION TO
CAGE FREE CANNOT SUDDENLY HAPPEN
AND TWENTY TWENTY FIVE TO THE
DATE THAT A LARGE NUMBER OF
RETAILERS CHOOSE AS THE DEADLINE
FOR THEIR COMMITMENTS.
FARMERS NEED TO BUILD NEW
HOUSING SYSTEMS YEAR BY YEAR IN
ORDER TO CONVERT THE ENTIRE AG
INDUSTRY TO CAGE FREE BY THAT
DAY.
GIVEN THE MAGNITUDE OF THIS
CONVERSION CALLERS THAT S. B.
INVESTED.
SOME MAJOR FOOD TOO RETAILERS
SUCH AS COSTCO COMPASS GROUP AND
OTHERS HAVE MADE CAGE FREE
PLEDGES THAT ARE MUCH SOONER TO
TAKE EFFECT.
AND THEY ARE IN NEED OF FARMERS
WHO HAVE MADE INVESTMENTS IN KEY
TREE SYSTEMS TO FILL THEIR SHELF
SPACE.
THAT'S WHAT I NEED CALIFORNIA
BALLOT INITIATIVE DOES.
THIS PROPOSED MEASURE WOULD
UPGRADE THE LOBBY TRIGGERING A
SHIFT TOWARDS CAGE FREE HOUSING
SYSTEMS FOR IDLING HANDS.
VEAL CALVES AND BREEDING PACKS
THE TRANSITION FOR EGG PRODUCERS
WILL HAPPEN OVER A MULTI YEAR
AND MULTI STEP PERIOD TO ENSURE
AN ORDERLY TRANSITION TO CAGE
FREE SYSTEMS.
CALIFORNIA HAS ALREADY BEEN A
LEADER IN THE PRODUCTION OF CAGE
FREE.
HOWEVER IN ORDER TO HAVE A
THRIVING GROWING INDUSTRY IN
CALIFORNIA THERE HAS TO BE
CERTAINTY FOR PRODUCERS.
IF THEY ARE IMPLEMENTING NEW
PRACTICES WHICH IS THE WAY THE
MARKET IS GROWING THEY NEED
CERTAINTY THAT THEY WILL BE ABLE
TO SELL THEIR EGGS PORK AND VEAL
FROM THE SYSTEMS.
SO THEY CAN HAVE A PLAN AND A
VAST APPROPRIATELY.
IT WILL ALSO ENSURE THAT
CALIFORNIA WILL HAVE A
COMPETITIVE EDGE IN SUPPLYING
THE ENORMOUS BURGEONING CAGE
FREE MARKET.
TIME AND TIME AGAIN WE SEE NOT
VOTERS LEARN THE TRUTH ABOUT
FACTORY FARMING AND ITS STRONG
RELATION TO FOOD SAFETY AND THEY
ARE READY TO EMBRACE A NEW
VISION FOR AGRICULTURE.
WHEN THAT INSURANCE OUR OPTICAL
VALUES AND PRINCIPLES OUR
CURRENT POLLING SHOWS
AVAILABILITY FOR CALIFORNIA
VOTERS AT THIS MEASURE AT A
STAGGERING 72%?
OF BOTH DEMOCRATS AND
REPUBLICANS THESE DAYS IT'S HARD
TO FIND ANY ISSUE WITH SUCH A
WIDESPREAD BIPARTISAN SUPPORT.
CALIFORNIA HAS LONG BEEN A
LEADER IN INNOVATION CREATING
CHANGE THAT THE REST OF THE
UNITED STATES TRIES TO FOLLOW.
PASSAGE OF THIS BALLOT IMAGE
INITIATIVE WILL SAN SHOOTS ABOUT
RECORD A WIN WITH THIS
PROPOSITION ON ELECTION DAY WILL
BE GOOD FOR ANIMALS CONSUMERS
AND FARMERS TRYING TO DO THE
RIGHT THING.
THANK YOU AND I'M LIKE TO DEFER
THE REST OF MY TIME TO DR JIM
REYNOLDS WHO IS A FARM ANIMAL
VETERINARIAN ENDORSER OF THIS
MEASURE.
A WELCOME THEM THANK YOU MADAM
CHAIRMAN.
THANK YOU FOR THE OPPORTUNITY TO
SPEAK IN SUPPORT OF THE ACT.
MY NAME IS JIM REYNOLDS I WAS
RAISED ON A DAIRY AND SAN DIEGO
QUITE AWHILE AGO.
I GRADUATED FROM UC DAVIS VERY
HIGH SCHOOL IN.
NINETEEN EIGHTY TWO AND AND I
PRACTICE BOVINE MEDICINE IN
SEVERAL AREAS CALIFORNIAN
PRIVATE PRACTICE.
I COMPLETED A RESIDENCY WITH THE
CALIFORNIA STATE HEALTH
DEPARTMENT.
THERE WAS CHIEF OF SERVICE FOR
DAIRY PRODUCTION MEDICINE FOR UC
DAVIS VETERINARY SCHOOL FOR
TWELVE YEARS AND CELERY.
I AM CURRENTLY A PROFESSOR OF
LARGE ANIMAL MEDICINE A WELFARE
FOR WESTERN UNIVERSITY.
OF HEALTH SERVICES COLLEGE OF
VETERINARY MEDICINE IN POMONA
CALIFORNIA.
HAVE WORKED INTERNATIONALLY.
IN LIVESTOCK PRODUCTION
HUMANITARIAN AID AND ANIMAL
WELFARE. TO CONCERT GOOD MY
BACKGROUND CONCLUDES I'VE CHAIR
THE AMERICAN VETERINARY MEDICAL
ASSOCIATION AND THE AMERICAN
BOVINE.
ASSOCIATION ABOVE I'M
PRACTITIONERS WELFARE COMMITTEES.
I AM CURRENTLY A MEMBER OF THE
CALIFORNIA VETERINARY MEDICAL
ASSOCIATION WELFARE COMMITTEE.
AND I AM BOARD CERTIFIED IN THE
SPECIALLY AREA OF ANIMAL WELFARE
[inaudible]
I HAVE.
I BELIEVE THAT WHEN WE USE
ANIMALS FOR PURPOSES.
INCLUDING RAISING THEM FOR FOOD.
WE HAVE RESPONSIBILITIES TO THE
ANIMALS.
WE MUST PROVIDE THEM WITH GOOD
LIVES PROVIDE BASIC COMMON SENSE
PRINCIPLES.
PLEASE BASIC NEEDS INCLUDE AMONG
OTHER THINGS ENOUGH SPACE SO
THEY CAN MOVE.
EXERCISE SOCIALIZE AND EXPRESSED
TYPICAL BEHAVIORS.
THIS WAS SOMETIMES CALLED THE
SOCIAL CONTRACT WE HAVE WITH
ANIMALS.
THE SALIENT PARTS ARE.
SOWS HANDS AND VEAL CALVES OUR
ALL SENTIMENT INTELLIGENT
ANIMALS BUT HAVE EMOTIONS AND
FEELINGS.
THESE ANIMALS HAVE BEHAVIORAL
NEEDS THAT INCLUDE.
THE NEED TO SOCIALIZE GROOM
EXERCISE AND EXPRESS OTHER
SPECIES TYPICAL BEHAVIORS.
THE SCIENCE OF ANIMAL WELFARE IS
VERY CLEAR.
THAT THESE ANIMALS NEED MORE
SPACE THAN JUST NATION CREDITS.
POULTRY CAGES UNVEIL CRATES
ALLOW.
ANIMALS COMBINED IN THE SMALL
SPACES DEMONSTRATES NARROW TEPES.
BOREDOM AND HAVE INCREASED RATES
OF METABOLIC AND INFECTIOUS
DISEASES.
THIS STATION CRATES POULTRY
CAGES AND REAL CRATES ARE NOT.
THERE FOR THE BENEFIT OF THE
ANIMALS.
BUT THE GAZE OF MANAGEMENT OF
THE PRODUCERS.
CONFINEMENT OF ANIMALS IN THE
SPACES THAT DO NOT ALLOW THEM TO
MOVE OR SOCIALIZE IS INHUMANE.
THE ACT WILL PROVIDE A
COMPROMISE BETWEEN WHAT ANIMALS
INVOLVED WANT AND NEED.
AND WHAT COMMERCIAL LIVESTOCK
PRODUCTION WANTS TO PROVIDE.
I THINK WE'LL TAKE QUESTIONS.
SAY WE HEARD BOTH THANK YOU --
A COUPLE QUESTIONS SO --
YOU BILL PROBABLY HAD
PROPOSITION TWO AND YOU WANNA
CAGE FREE HOUSING --
WHY DID YOU NOT RATE PROPS TO TO
REQUIRE CAGE FREE HOUSING THEN?
SURE -- AS A
MEMBER HOW COULD I NOT KNOW --
ON BEHALF OF THE COALITION IN
SUPPORT OF OF THE INITIATIVE --
NEAR THIS IS AN INCREMENTAL
PROCESS --
DID -- PROP
TWO WASN'T IF I THINK THE FIRST
IN THE NATION OF ITS KIND --
INSIDE AND IT'S IT'S SORT OF
INCREMENTAL IN TERMS OF PHASING
IN NOT TRYING TO BE TOO DRASTIC
IN TERMS OF THE PRODUCERS COSTS --
SO STEP BY STEP APPROACH --
AND MAKES IT EASIER BILL FOR THE
FOR TO HANDLE IT IN THE DISTANCE
ON THE MARKET TO JUST AS WELL.
SO -- WE
REQUIRE FIRE THE FARMERS TO
UPGRADE IT MILLIONS AND MILLIONS
AND MILLIONS OF DOLLARS.
SO WE HAVE THIS NEXT PHASE
COMING IN.
WHAT'S NOT.
HOW CAN WE GUARANTEE YOU NOTHING
COME BACK IN A COUPLE YEARS AND
REQUIRE MORE REGULATIONS ON OUR
FARMERS?
SURE WILL UP AS YOU JUST SAID IS
PHASED IN.
SO IS THIS THE END OF PHASES.
OVER YOU HAVE LUIS MEASURES AND
AT LEAST FOR ON A HEN
CONFINEMENT --
YOU THE ULTIMATE THE AND AND
RESULT IS IT ADOPTS INDUSTRY
STANDARD --
AS AS THE THE FINAL AYE NOT SIZE
YOU REQUIREMENTS FOR FOR POULTRY
CAGES SO IT'S WHATEVER'S THE IN
THE IN INDUSTRIES --
SORT OF BEST PRACTICE THAT'S
THAT'S WHAT THE INITIATIVE
REQUIRES [inaudible]
SO THAT'S IT DID MOVES OVER TO
WHAT WHAT THE POULTRY INDUSTRY
IS DETERMINED TO BE DEEP IN THE
MOST APPROPRIATE HOUSING
STANDARDS THAT'S INITIATIVE.
BUT IT'S THE TO TWENTY SEVENTEEN
ON UNITED EGG PRODUCERS ANIMAL
HAS BEEN TO YOU HUSBANDRY
GUIDELINES.
I JUST SORT I DON'T SEE THIS
GETTING OUT OF CONTROL AND MEANS
YOU KNOW I UNDERSTAND I'M PAUL
FOR MAKING SURE THINGS ARE
HUMANE.
BUT I ALSO HAVE TO GO BACK TO
THE COST TO THEFARMER THE COST
TO THE ECONOMY THE COST TO MY
CONSUMERS.
AND I GOT TO I REALLY WORRY
ABOUT MY CONSUMERS IF THERE'S
ANYTHING LOT OF MY PEOPLE ARE ON
LIMITED.
INCOME AND CHICKENS ONE OF THE
TOP --
PRODUCTS THAT THEY EAT.
AND SO THE EVERYTIME SOMETHING
GOES UP REFERENCES STATE
CALIFORNIA SO EXPENSIVE YOU KNOW
THIS IS JUST ONE OF THEM.
AND SURE BY CHRISTOPHER TALK
ABOUT COST YES YES SO THE
INITIATIVE ONLY COVERS ACTS THAT
I SHALL AND LIQUID ADS.
AND WOOD IS COMPANIES LIKE
MCDONALD'S AND WALMART MAKING
THESE CONVERSIONS I REALLY
SPECIALIZE IN IN KEEPING PRICES
LOW.
THERE'S BEEN A LOT OF STUDIES
DONE AND HEARD TOO HOT CONSUMERS
WOULD BE AND THAT RANGES ABOUT
ONE TO TWO SAM PER AG.
THAT CONSUMERS WOULD WOULD HAVE
THE IMPACT OF WHOM I'M THAT SO
HARD TO BELIEVE HER NEPHEW IN
AND BY.
THANKS RECENTLY BUT THEY'VE GONE
SKY HIGH.
OKAY THANK YOU.
WELL IT'S NOT JUST IT'S IT'S IN
COMPARISON TO STATES THAT DON'T
HAVE THE SAME.
REGULATIONS THAT THERE THE
DIFFERENCES FAIRLY SIGNIFICANT.
MR MATHIS ARM.
YEAH I MEAN IT.
HOW MANY MORE PHASES YEARS HAVE?
BUT AGAIN DOESN'T IT ASSEMBLY
MEMBER MATHIS THIS I CAN ONLY BE
CHANGED BY THE VOTERS TIME SO
YOU KNOW IT THE I UNDERSTAND IT
DOESN'T TAKE INTO THAT VOTERS AS
AND THAT WON'T BE ENOUGH.
THAT SLOWS THE PROCESS ISSUE
NUMBER.
I'M SORRY YOU SAID YOU HAVE A
PLAN TO TO FEES AND SO WHAT IS
YOUR ULTIMATE GOAL.
BUT WE START WITH HIS YOU WOULD
HAVE WROTE THIS AND TO PROP TO
YOU WHEN YOU DIDN'T BECAUSE YOU
WANTED TO MOVE BACK OR MENTALLY.
AND E. E. OF COST INDUSTRY IN
CALIFORNIA THOUGH OVER TWO
HUNDRED FIFTY MILLION DOLLARS
YOU'VE INCREASE THE COST OF EGGS.
WAIT WHICH HAS A NET INCREASE ON
OTHER STATE BUDGETS NOT NOT AS
FOOD AND AG BUT I MEAN YOU ALSO
HAVE TO LOOK AT THE NUMBER OF
THE YOU KNOW OUR OUR PROGRAMS
LIKE WAKING CAL FRESH GIVE ACHES
TO FAMILIES WHO ARE IN NEED.
WHICH IS THEN ANOTHER INCURRED.
ARE BUDGETARY [inaudible]
THAT -- CAN
YOU KNOW FOR THE STATE WE HAVE
TO EAT THAT COST.
AND SO I MEAN IF IT IS THE LA O.
I I SHOULD ASK THIS QUESTION OF
THE LA A A LA OR DO YOU HAVE ANY
NUMBERS ON THE INCREASED COSTS
FOR THAT THE WAKE PROGRAMS OR
CAL FRESH --
IN IN NUMBERS ON HOW MANY
FAMILIES ARE GETTING EGGS AND
THE INCREASED COST OF THE STATE
THERE.
AS SOMEONE LEGISLATIVE ANALYST'S
OFFICE IDON'T HAVE THAT
INFORMATION AVAILABLE TO BE
RIGHT NOW TO SHARE WITH YOU --
I KNOW THAT THEY THAT INCLUDED
IN THE MEASURE THERE IS ADD A
PROVISION THAT THAT AS I AS I
UNDERSTAND IT.
THAT WOULD REQUIRE THAT THE
MEASURE --
SUPERSEDES THAT THE REQUIREMENTS
ON IS IT THIS.
THE SUPPLEMENTAL NUTRITION.
I'VE PROGRAM BUT AS FOR HOW MUCH
TO TIP ATTENTION THE INCREASED
COSTS FOR THE PROGRAMS THAT YOU
JUST NAMED I DON'T HAVE AN
ESTIMATE. FOR A I ASK THAT
BECAUSE IN MY DISTRICT WE YOU
KNOW FIFTY SIX FOR SOME OF MY
DISTRICT IS ON SOME KIND OF US
LEGISLATOR MEDIC CALLERS
pAND YOU KNOW THE AVERAGE INCOME
IS UNDER THIRTY FIVE THOUSAND
HERE.
SELL IT IS WE GO TO INCREASE
THESE THINGS AND WE'RE HAVING A
HARD ENOUGH TIME.
ENSURING THAT FAMILIES CAN
LITERALLY FEED THEIR FAMILIES --
VERSUS HAVING TO MAKE OTHER
CHOICES ON YOU KNOW HOW MUCH GAS
TO PUT IN THEIR TANK.
AND SO WE YOU KNOW HERE WE ARE
WITH WITH ANOTHER PHASE --
THAT THEY COULD HAVE BEEN
WRITTEN BEFORE.
ARM.
I I JUST HAVE A HARD TIME.
SEEN HOW FAMILIES CAN --
DIGEST --
ALL THESE INCREASES.
SO A SUMMER MATHIS MAYBE I CAN --
DE UM ELABORATE ON THAT IN IN I
THINK IN TWO THOUSAND EIGHT
THERE WAS MUCH MORE DISAGREEMENT
TWEEN ANIMAL WELFARE GROUPS AND
AND AGRICULTURE.
INDUSTRY IN TERMS OF THE PROPER
OR YOU KNOW --
THE INDIA CONFINEMENT STANDARDS
FOR FOR ANIMALS WE'VE MOVED TO A
POINT NOW WHERE IN THE
INITIATIVE [inaudible]
WE ADOPT.
THE UNITED EGG PRODUCERS ANIMAL
HUSBANDRY GUIDELINES SO I THINK
WE'VE REACHED A POINT IN THAT
SORT OF IN THIS PHASE IN A
PROCESS THAT ACTUALLY AGREEMENT
BETWEEN ANIMAL WELFARE GROUPS.
AND PRODUCERS --
OF WHAT THE PROPER STANDARDS ARE
I THINK THAT'S A GOOD THAT'S OF
BUT THAT'S A GREAT DEVELOPMENT
FRANKLY BUT BUT BUT AS AS YOU
JUST TESTIFIED.
THE MARKETS ARE YOU DOING THIS
YOU JUST SAID COSCO'S ALREADY
ADOPTING THIS SO OF THE MARKET'S
RD DOING IT ON OUR OWN WHAT'S
THE NEED FOR A MEASURE. TO
ENSURE THAT THERE'S NO OUT
LETTERS IN THE MARKET.
EXCUSE ME THAT ALL ANIMALS HAVE
THE PROPER PROTECTIONS.
SO WE'RE MORE CONCERNED BUT THE
OTHER THING IS TO SET A DATE.
RIGHT I MEAN THAT'S WHAT IT DOES
IS IT DOES NOT ADDRESS THE DATE
AND I THINK IT SAM.
IT SIGNIFICANT THAT THERE'S
AGREEMENT.
MY CONCERN IN AND WE'LL HEAR
FROM THE OPPOSITION --
IT'S JUST WHETHER THE DATE WORKS --
I'VE HAD AN OPPORTUNITY TO DO
ACTORS ALL OF THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA AND I'VE HAD AN
OPPORTUNITY TO VISIT FARMS.
AND I DON'T THINK THERE'S
DISAGREEMENT ABOUT GETTING. TO
THIS NEW STANDARD THE QUESTION
IS AMORTIZING THE COST OVERTIME
AND THEN GETTING ENOUGH.
HAVING ENOUGH TIME TO ACTUALLY
MOVE THE EQUIPMENT OUT BRING IN
NEW AND HAVE IT LINE UP WITH
WHEN -- WHEN
THAT THEIR HANDS ARE PRODUCING?
FROM THE HAND PERSPECTIVE SO --
MINIMUM PORTENT PART THAT I HEAR
FROM FARMERS WHO ARE LOOKING TO
MAKE THESE INVESTMENTS BECAUSE
THEY KNOW THE WRITING'S ON THE
WALL.
PROP TO LIZ THIRTEEN YOU KNOW
YEARS AGO THAT THIS WAS THAT THE
IDEA WAS ADOPTED.
AND GOING BACK TO WHAT I SAID
ABOUT PROVIDING CERTAINTY BEINGS
NEED TO UNDERSTAND THAT THEY
ALSO HAVE.
YOU KNOW THAT THEY'RE MAKING THE
RIGHT INVESTMENTS THESE FARMERS
AND LOANING MONEY AND THAT
THEY'RE LOANING MONEY TO
SOMETHING.
THAT IS GOING TO BE BOUGHT BY
CONSUMERS AND IT IS GOING TO BE
THE MAINSTREAM IDEA.
SO IT ALSO DOES PROVIDE
CERTAINTY.
I WANT TO HELP THEM UPGRADE BOB
BY CONCERNED CONSUMERS BECAUSE I
MEAN THIS IS A VITAL PART OF OUR
DIET THIS IS --
IS REASON WHY WAKING CAO FRESH
COVER THINGS LIKE EGGS ON THEIR
THE PROGRAM SO.
THAT ARE GONNA BE FOUGHT BECAUSE
TO CONSUMERS WILL REALLY HAVE
ANY OTHER CHOICE.
BOB ON ON IN ALL THE OTHER
PEOPLE UP HERE ON THE DICE BY BE
OKAY WITH TO THE INCREASE
ADDITIONAL COST TO FARMERS AND
HAVING A LOT MORE MONEY TO THEM
AND EVERYTHING ELSE AND I'D LIKE
TO SEE THEM PROSPER.
THE AS IT IS AND I'M I'M MORE
CONCERNED ABOUT.
YOU KNOW MONEY. FOR THE FAMILIES
THAT ARE OUT THERE STRUGGLING
AND CALIFORNIA'S OVER REGULATORY
SYSTEM AS IT IS.
WHO ARE TRYING TO PROVIDE FOR
THEIR FAMILIES?
AND I JUST DON'T SEE HOW. ONE
MORE PHASE.
AS YOU ALL PUT AID IS GOING TO
HELP FAMILIES AT THE END OF THE
DAY.
BEAT BECAUSE WE WE HAVE TOO MANY
FAMILIES STRUGGLING AS IT IS NOW.
AND AS FROM STATE BUDGET TORY
SANTORUM YEAH WE JUST PASSED THE
LARGEST THE BUDGET IN HISTORY.
BUT SHE ONLY PROGRAMS ALREADY
OUT OVER LOG.
IN YOUR MEASURES GOING TO
INCREASE.
THE BURDEN ON THE STATE AND IT'S
GOING TO INCREASE.
MORE REGULATORY MARKUPS AND
WHERE ARE YOU HAVE PEOPLE THAT
ARE STRUGGLING [inaudible]
CHAU.
AND MEAN IT.
HOUSE IS GONNA HELP FAMILIES OUT
THERE THAT ARE STRUGGLING DAY
ABOUT IT ASSEMBLY MEMBER I THINK
COME OUR STUDIES SHOW THAT IT
THE COST IS ABOUT ONE TO TWO
CENTS PER A. B..
TIED WITH WE SURE THAT'S A GOOD
IDEA I DON'T WANT ONE IF THERE
WERE A ON TOP A TWELVE CENTS A
GALLON INCREASE WILL HAVE OF
EVERYTHING ELSE MY FRIEND THAT
THIS MEASURE OF THE COVER THOSE
OTHER ITEMS I SO WE WON'T TAKE
CREDIT OR BLAME FOR THOSE BUT
THE COST.
IS MINIMAL IN TERMS OF THE IN
TERMS OF CLINTON IMPLEMENTING
THIS MEASURE.
SO MR LIVING YOU HAD A
QUESTIONER INCREASE.
SURE IT'S THANK YOU VERY MUCH
AND I THINK YOU ALL FOR
PARTICIPATING THIS IS GREAT THAT
WE WILL HAVE THESE HEARINGS ON
THESE BALLOT INITIATIVES --
I THINK THAT THAT PROP TWO IN
TWO THOUSAND CERTAINLY MOVED TO
CONVERSATION IT WAS IN PERFECT
AND WE'VE WORKS AS THE
LEGISLATURE TO MAKE IT WORK FOR
CALIFORNIA.
AND PERHAPS YOU LEARN A LITTLE
BIT FROM THAT IN YOUR APPROACH
HERE -- BUT
I THINK IT IS AS YOU'VE HEARD IN
THE CONVERSATION WE'VE HAD THERE
ARE A LOT OF ISSUES THAT WE DEAL
WITH IN THE LEGISLATURE AND WE
TRY -- TO
YOU KNOW CONSIDER WHEN MAKING
LAWS.
AND HERE YOU ARE USING THE
INITIATIVE SYSTEM TO INVENT
SOMETHING WHEN YOU ACTUALLY
COULD WORK WITH THE LEGISLATURE.
TO PASS LAWS TO GET TO THE SAME
EFFECT THAT YOU WANTED WHY WOULD
YOU GO AHEAD AND USE THE
INITIATIVE SYSTEM.
RATHER THAN ACTUALLY BEING AN
ADVOCATE.
AND WORKING TO PASS LAWS.
SURE -- I
THINK A MY BILL THE DRESS THAT
PROPOSITION --
TWO COVERS THE SAME ANIMALS --
IF IT AGAIN AND AND MORE OFTEN
IT IS EASY I THINK YOU --
MENTIONED SOMETHING MEMBERS OF
THE FIRST STEP TOM THERE'S NO
PROVISION FOR LEGISLATIVE
AMENDMENTS THAT WAS THE FIRST UP.
YEAH WELL BE BOMBS ARE I DIE I
GET SOME --
THERE'S NO PROVISION FOR
AMENDMENTS IN THIS INITIATIVE --
BY THE LEGISLATURE --
FRANTIC ACTION SO THAT THERE IS
A NEED TO HAVE AN INITIATIVE TO
TO MODIFY THE STANDARDS.
AND AND SECONDARILY --
HOW MUCH EXTRA MONEY TO YOUR
ORGANIZATIONS REYES IN TWO
THOUSAND EIGHT AND ARE YOU
ANTICIPATING RAISING TO IT AGAIN
TEN YEARS LATER?
I I DON'T HAVE THOSE NUMBERS HOW
MUCH WAS RAISED IN BUT THAT THAT
INFORMATION PUBLICLY AVAILABLE --
CAMPAIGN REPORT.
ON THE SECTOR SIX WEBSITE AND
SINCE.
SINCE THE LA WAS UNABLE TO
ANSWER HOW HOW MANY OF THE
SIGNATURES WERE PAID VERSES ON
PAID.
SO WE I DON'T HAVE EXACT
BREAKDOWN BUT I DO KNOW
ANECDOTALLY THAT THIS CAMPAIGN
HAD MORE VOLUNTEERS SIGNATURES
COLLECTED THAN ANY OTHER
MEASURES THAT WILL APPEAR ON THE
BALLOT IN NOVEMBER.
TWENTY EIGHTEEN AND HOW MUCH
MONEY DID YOU GUYS SPEND ON
COLLECTING SIGNATURES ARE THAT
IS ALL PUBLICLY REPORTED THAT
THE SECTOR STATES WEBSITE THAT
INFORMATION COULD BE FOUND.
SO I GOT WHO LATER YOU GONNA
GIVE ME AND OTHER THE CALIFORNIA
SECRETARY OF STATE HOUSING
INFORMATION ON HIS WEB PAGE YEAH
IT'S I CAN ASK SYRIA RIGHT NOW
I'M ASKING YOU KNOW I I DON'T
HAVE THE NUMBER.
RIGHT FROM I WOULD I WOULD DO
THE SAME THING I WOULD GO TO THE
SECTOR SUSPICION BECAUSE WELL
IT'S ALL AVAILABLE FOR THE
PUBLIC TO LOOK AT THANK YOU.
ANY OTHER QUESTIONS.
THANKS VERY MUCH APPRECIATE YOUR
TIME.
PANEL NUMBER THREE IS JOHN
BIGELOW J. S. WEST EGG PRODUCER.
AND BRADLEY MILLER THE
CALIFORNIA CALIFORNIANS AGAINST
CRYPTIC CAGES AND FRAUD CAMPAIGN
[inaudible]
WELCOME.
A GOOD MORNING AND I WANT TO
THANK THE COMMITTEE FOR ALLOWING
ME TO SPEAK TODAY --
MY NAME IS JOHN BUT AL.
AND I WORK FOR A HUNDRED AND
NINE YEAR OLD FAMILY FORMA
MODESTO CALIFORNIA THAT RAISES
CHICKENS AND I'M A THIRD
GENERATION CHICKEN FARMER.
WHICH MY SEVENTY EIGHT YEAR OLD
MOTHER.
STILL DOES TODAY SO I AM VERY
PASSIONATE ABOUT THIS ISSUE.
AND I KNOW IT'S COMING OUT TODAY
AND I GOT TO GET BACK TO WORK
AND MAKE SOME EGGS SO I'VE GOT
MY COMMENTS --
WRITTEN AT SO I SAY WITHIN MY
TIMELINE BUT THERE WILL BE SOME
PASSION.
THIS INITIATIVE IS ANOTHER
POORLY WRITTEN AND ILLINOIS VISE
ATTACK ON THE AG INDUSTRY ONLY
THREE YEARS AFTER COMPLYING WITH
THE NATION'S STRICTEST HOUSING
STANDARDS FOR CHICKENS
PROPOSITION.
TWO CALIFORNIA EGG FARMERS JUST
SPENT TWO HUNDRED AND FIFTY
MILLION DOLLARS AND THE STATE
LOS THE PRODUCTION OF SEVEN
MILLION LAYING HANDS.
FORCING CONSUMERS TO BUY MORE
EXPENSIVE OUT OF STATE AIDS.
THE LOCAL FARM TO FORK MOVEMENT
TOOK AN ARROW IN THE LATE
JANUARY.
ONE TWO THOUSAND FIFTEEN NOT TO
MENTION THE JOBS THAT WERE LOST
IN THE STATE AND MONEY THAT
TRANSFER DIRECTLY INTO THE
MIDWEST PIG FARMERS POCKETS.
ALREADY LIMPING FROM THE LAST
FIGHT.
NOW THE SAME BATTLE ONCE AGAIN
THIS TIME GUARANTEEING THE DEATH
OF EVEN MORE FAMILY FARMS.
UNLESS LOCAL FOR FOOD PRODUCED
BY CALIFORNIANS FOR CALIFORNIANS
[inaudible]
ANIMAL WELFARE.
SORRY ANIMAL WELFARE AND HEALTH.
IS EVERYTHING TO THE CHICKEN
FARMER.
MOST CONSUMERS HAVE NEVER BEEN
ON A FARM.
MUCH LESS UNDERSTAND THE SCIENCE
OF ANIMAL BEHAVIOR.
H. AT YOU S. USES A MOTIONS AND
IGNORANCE. TO GET POLICIES LIKE
THIS PASS WOULD NEVER THINK
ABOUT WHAT THIS MEANS THE LOCAL
STATE AND NATIONAL ECONOMIES.
AND OUR ABILITY TO PROVIDE
LOCALLY GROWN PRODUCTS THE EGG
INDUSTRY HAS BEEN MOVING TOWARDS
CAGE FREE PRODUCTION FOR DECADES.
MAJOR RETAILERS RESTAURANTS HAVE
MADE COMMITMENTS TO CAGE FREE
ONLY A EGGS THEY'VE BEEN WORKING
DIRECTLY WITH EGG FARMERS.
PLANNING SO SUPPLY AND COST TO
CONSUMERS WILL BE MANAGEABLE.
TWO THOUSAND TWENTY FIVE HAS
BEEN THE TARGET DATE.
AND NOW FOR SOME ARBITRARY
REASON THIS NEEDS TO HAPPEN
THREE YEARS AHEAD OF SCHEDULE.
THREE YEARS MAY SEEM
INSIGNIFICANT TO MOST PEOPLE BUT
THE TIME NECESSARY TO BUILD
BARNS IN THIS STATE.
WITH ALL THE LAND USE
REQUIREMENTS IS ABSOLUTELY
DAUNTING [inaudible]
SO.
ANOTHER TWO HUNDRED FIFTY
MILLION DOLLARS WILL BE SPENT.
21% OF THIS STATES CAGE LAYERS.
WILL BE SENT OUT OF STATE.
THE MAJOR PROBLEM HERE.
IS THE TIMELINE.
A STAFF ASSOCIATION OF
CALIFORNIA EGG FARMERS ARE
FAMILY FARMERS THAT HAVE FED
CALIFORNIANS FOR GENERATIONS.
THE ONCE LARGEST A PRODUCING
STATE IN THE NATION IS AGAIN
BEING SYSTEMATICALLY WHITTLE
DOWN THROUGH A BILL DESIGNED
INITIATIVES LIKE THIS.
CASE THAT HAS ALWAYS STRIVED TO
PROVIDE CALIFORNIA CONSUMERS
WITH WHOLESOME [inaudible]
AFFORDABLE FOOD.
ACCELERATED TO TWENTY TWO DATE
WILL HURT THE MOST ECONOMICALLY
CHALLENGED CALIFORNIA FAMILIES.
THE RESPONSIBLE COURSE OF ACTION
WOULD BE TO RECOGNIZE WHAT MAJOR
RETAILERS AND CONSUMER TRENDS
HAVE ALREADY PLANNED.
FOR USE A TWO TWENTY FIVE DATE.
STOP FORCING MORE ECONOMIC
BURDEN ON THE STATE BECAUSE ONE
VOCAL GROUP HAS MISINFORMED
PEOPLE WHO DO NOT TRULY
UNDERSTAND ALL THE ISSUES.
HOW MUCH WILL THIS COST?
THE LOWEST INCOME CALIFORNIANS
HAVE TO BEAR THE BURDEN ONCE
AGAIN BEFORE WE SEE THE REAL.
PROBLEM HERE.
OKAY IN A PERFECT WORLD WE WOULD
ALL LIVE ON SMALL FARMS AND
PRODUCE OUR OWN FOOD.
FINISH OF A NEGATIVE LIKE THIS
WOULD NEVER BE CONSIDERED.%
THE REALITY IS MUCH DIFFERENT.
FORTY MILLION HUNGRY
CALIFORNIANS DEPEND ON FAMILY
FARMS AND EXPECT VALUE FOR THEIR
HARD EARNED DOLLAR.
THIS INITIATIVE WILL INCREASE
THE COST OF FOOD.
ACOSTA AGRICULTURAL ENFORCEMENT.
JOBS WILL BE LOST OR MOVED TO
OTHER STATES TAX REVENUE WILL BE
LOST AND SO WILL LOCAL FARMERS.
H. ISSUE S. AND OUR ALLIES WROTE.
PROP.
TWO CALIFORNIA FARMERS HAVE
SPENT HUNDREDS OF MILLIONS OF
DOLLARS TO COMPLY AND SEVERAL
MILLION DOLLARS ANNUALLY FOR TO
ENFORCE.
AND WHAT IS THE RESULT.
HIGHER PRICES FOR POOR
CALIFORNIANS.
LET'S CALIFORNIA GROWN EGGS
[inaudible]
EXPENSIVE LAWSUITS.
AND NOW THEY'RE BACK.
WE OPPOSE ENCOURAGE YOU ALL TO
OPPOSE AND FIND A REASONABLE
ALTERNATIVE [inaudible]
THANK YOU --
MADAM CHAIR MEMBERS --
THANKS FOR THIS OPPORTUNITY.
MY NAME IS BRADLEY MILLER I'M A
SPOKESPERSON FOR CALIFORNIANS
AGAINST CRUELTY CAGES AND FRAUD.
A WE HAVE ARE THE BALLOT
COMMITTEE THAT WILL BE PRIMARILY --
CHARGED WITH --
OPPOSING THIS INITIATIVE --
WHICH WE REFER TO AS THE ROTTEN
EGG INITIATIVE WE WILL HEAD UP
TO THE NO ONE PROPOSITION
WHATEVER.
IT AND NUMBER IT WINDS UP
GETTING --
I'D LIKE TO POINT OUT THAT
THEY'RE REALLY.
CLOSER TO THREE SIDES OF THIS
ISSUE.
WE COULD SAY THERE'S TWO SIDES
WITH THERE'S ACTUALLY THREE
SITES --
THERE'S THE AGES U. S. POSITION.
THAT BELIEVES THAT --
WHAT THEY SAID ABOUT PROPOSITION
TWO SHOULD BE COMPLETELY IGNORED?
THAT CALIFORNIA SHOULD NOT BE
CAGE FREE IN THE YEAR TWO
THOUSAND AND FIFTEEN BUT RATHER
WE SHOULD EXPLICITLY KEEP CAGES
LEGAL IN THE STATE. FOR A
CERTAIN NUMBER OF ADDITIONAL
YEARS.
AGES YOU S. BELIEVES THAT THE
GUIDELINES OF UNITED EGG
PRODUCERS SHOULD BE INSERTED
INTO CALIFORNIA STATE LAW.
THE EGG INDUSTRY AGREES WITH
THEM ON THOSE PRIMARY POINTS.
WE DISAGREE WITH BOTH THE EGG
INDUSTRY AND H. AS YOU S. ON
THOSE POINTS.
THE DISCREPANCY SEEMS TO BE
[inaudible]
ALMOST NONEXISTENT.
THE REASON WHY NOW IN IN THEIR
PRESENTATION THEY METICULOUSLY
AVOIDED.
SAYING ANYTHING SPECIFICALLY
SPECIFICALLY ABOUT THE CONTENT
OF THE INITIATIVE THAT THEY
WOULD LIKE TO CREATE A STATE LAW.
THEY WERE ASKED VERY DIRECT
QUESTIONS AND I'M NOT GOING FROM
PREPARED STATEMENTS HERE I'M
GOING TO TRY AND FILL IN SOME OF
THE GAPS THAT THEY DELIBERATELY
LEFT OPEN.
SENATOR YOU ASKED --
IN NO PARTICULAR ORDER U. S. --
FOR WAS THIS TRULY A VOLUNTEER
BASED EFFORT --
IF YOU LOOK AT THEIR RHETORIC
THIS WAS A GREAT IS VOLUNTEER
EFFORT THAT THEY SURPASSED ALL
THEIR EXPECTATIONS.
THROUGHOUT THEIR CAMPAIGN THERE
WERE VOLUNTEERS LEAVING IN
DROVES AS THEY FOUND OUT WHAT
THIS COULD THE CONTENT OF THIS
MEASURE DID.
THEY THEMSELVES ADMITTED ALL
ALONG THE LINE THAT THEY WERE
WELL BEHIND IT THEIR SIGNATURE
GATHERING CAMPAIGN THAT THEY HAD
INTENDED TO DO THIS FOR
VOLUNTEERS. TO THE BEST OF OUR
ABILITIES THE NUMBERS THAT WE
HAVE BASED ON THE NUMBERS
PUBLISHED BY THE PROPONENTS
THEMSELVES.
IT APPEARS THAT THERE WERE AS
THEY SAID THEY DID SAY ONE THING
CORRECTLY.
THAT THERE WERE ABOUT SIX
HUNDRED SIXTY FOUR THOUSAND
NAMES GATHERED [inaudible]
APPARENTLY.
ONLY A HUNDRED AND SIXTY FOUR
APPROXIMATELY.
THOUSAND WERE GATHERED BY
VOLUNTEERS THE REMAINDER.
WERE FROM PAID SIGNATURE
GATHERERS.
THE VAST MAJORITY OF WHICH WERE
PAYING A BOUNTY PER SIGNATURE.
SO.
WHAT TROUBLES US IS NOT SIMPLY
THAT THEY WERE PAYING FOR THE
SIGNATURES ISN'T THE WORD
MISLEADING PEOPLE WHILE THEY
WERE GATHERING THOSE SIGNATURES?
THIS IS A ONE OF THEIR KEY
PIECES OF CAMPAIGN MATERIAL
RIGHT HERE AND AS YOU CAN SEE IT
SAYS.
VOTE YES TO PREVENT CRUELTY IN
CALIFORNIA.
PREVENT CRUELTY IN CALIFORNIA.
AND HERE YOU CAN SEE A PICTURE
OF A VEAL CRATE AND THE CALF
INTO VEAL CRATE.
YOU COULD SEE A PICTURE OF A
PAGAN AGES STATION CRAIG.
YOU CAN SEE THE OF THE REALLY
COMPELLING PHOTOS.
THAT JUST SO HAPPENED TO BE
TAKEN OUT OF STATE.
MANY YEARS AGO WERE THE SAME
IMAGES THAT THEY USEWHILE
PROMOTING PROPOSITION.
TWO AND NONE OF THESE PRACTICES
EXIST IN OUR STATE.
THEIR WORD VEAL CRATES IN
CALIFORNIA AT THE TIME OF PROP.
TWO THERE ARE NO WE JUST STATION
CRATES IN CALIFORNIA NOW AND
HAVEN'T BEEN FOR YEARS BUT THEY
HAVE GOTTEN PEOPLE TO SIGN THAT
PETITION BASED ON THE CLAIM THAT
THEY WILL BE PREVENTING THESE
PRACTICES.
IN CALIFORNIA.
THEY WERE IVEN A DIRECT
QUESTION AS TO WHY PROPOSITION
TWO IF IF IT WAS TO BAN CAGES.
WHY DIDN'T IT SAY THIS BANDS
CAGES?
AND THAT'S THE KEY QUESTION AND
THAT'S WHY WE'RE HERE TODAY.
IT'S NOT LIKE WELL WAY BACK IN
TWO THOUSAND AND EIGHT OO IN
THOSE DAYS WE DIDN'T KNOW THAT
IF YOU WANNA BAN CAGES YOU HAVE
TO SAY IN THE TEXT OF THE
LEGISLATION.
CAGES.
THEY WE KNEW IN TWO THOUSAND AND
EIGHT IF YOU WANNA GIVE A HAND
TWO HUNDRED SIXTEEN SQUARE
INCHES OR MORE OF CAGE SPACE OR
LIVING SPACE THAT YOU.
PUT THAT INTO THE LEGISLATION
YOU PUT THAT INTO THE INITIATIVE.
THEY MADE THE CONSCIOUS CHOICE
NOT TO DO THAT THEY MADE THE
CONSCIOUS CHOICE OF PUTTING IN
VERY VAGUE LANGUAGE.
SO THEY DEPENDING ON WHAT
AUDIENCE THEY WERE.
SELLINGTHIS TO DATE COULD CRAFT
THEIR ARGUMENT ACCORDINGLY YOU
DON'T WANT CAGES WELL THIS
DOESN'T SAY CAGES YOU WANT A PET
CAGE AS WELL THIS IS A DE FACTO
BAN ON CAGES.
CALIFORNIA VOTERS WENT TO THE
POLLS IN TWO THOUSAND EIGHT AND
OVERWHELMINGLY VOTED FOR
SOMETHING THAT THEY WERE TOLD.
BY BOTH SIDES OF THE ISSUE BY H.
AS U. S. AND BY THE INDUSTRY
ITSELF THAT IF THIS MEASURE
PASSES.
CAGES WOULD BE BANNED BY TWO
THOUSAND AND FIFTEEN AND THEY
WOULD BE GETTING NO LESS A TWO
HUNDRED SQUARE INCHES
[inaudible]
HER HAND.
NO AES U. S. IS COME HERE TODAY
TO TALK ABOUT THE EGG INDUSTRIES.
DISINGENUOUS MISINTERPRETATION
OF PROPOSITION.
TWO WE ARE ONE OF THE BOTH
FERVENT ADVERSARIES OF THE AG
INDUSTRY.
UNLIKE H. AS U. S. WE HAVE NOT
ENDORSED THIS GENTLEMAN'S
FACILITY.
WE DID NOT HOLD THIS GENTLEMAN'S
FACILITY UP AS A MODEL FOR THE
NATION LIKE H. AS U. S. DID.
NOW THEY'RE NOT DOING THAT TODAY
BECAUSE THEY'RE FLIP FLOPPING
BACK AND FORTH DEPENDING ON THE
CIRCUMSTANCES.
BUT WE'VE BEEN CONSISTENT IN
SAYING THAT IT'S THE VOTER
INTENT THAT MATTERS HERE.
AND THERE'S NO DEBATE THAT THE
VOTER INTENT WAS THAT THERE TO
BE A DEADLINE TO TWO THOUSAND
AND FIFTEEN THE DISINGENUOUS
MISINTERPRETED HER PETITION
REINTERPRETATION.
IS FOR THE SPONSORS OF PROP.
TWO COULD NOT OWN UP TO THEIR
MISTAKE.
A ASSEMBLYMAN LEVINE ASKS WHY
CAN'T WE SETTLE THIS
LEGISLATIVELY.
THE ANSWER IS THEY'RE NOT THE
DIFFERENCE ISN'T SIMPLY THAT
THEY WILL WANT TO KEEP THEM IN
CAGES TWENTY FOUR MONTHS LONGER
THAN AGES U. S. WANTS TO KEEP
THEM IN CAGES IT'S NOT SIMPLY
THAT THEY WANT TO MEAN CAGES FOR
NINE YEARS AFTER PROPOSITION TWO
WAS SUPPOSED TO GO.
INTO EFFECT AN AGE ISSUE WHAT'S
IN YEARS AFTER THAT.
WITH THE LEGISLATION IT BECOMES
CLEAR.
IF.
IF IF THEY HAD BEEN CORRECT
ABOUT.
WHAT PROPOSITION TWO SAID WE
WOULD NOT BE HERE TODAY?
IF THEY WERE TELLING THE TRUTH
ABOUT THEIR PRESENT ROTTEN
INITIATIVE.
WE WOULD BE AMONG THE FIRST TO
SUPPORT IT.
pBELIEVE THAT THIS AND VOTERS
HAVE ALREADY SPOKEN CALIFORNIANS
HAVE ALREADY FOLKS SPOKANE.
AND WE DON'T BELIEVE THAT
CALIFORNIA'S BALLOT MEASURE
SYSTEM.
SHOULD BE EXPLOITED [inaudible]
BY.
ANIMAL THEMED CORPORATIONS FROM
THE EAST COAST THAT EVERY
SEVERAL YEARS OR SO FLYING INTO
CALIFORNIA.
AND TELL CALIFORNIANS HOW WE
SHOULD REGULATE AT FARM ANIMALS
NOTIN OUR STATE ONLY IN OUR
STATE.
BUT IN OTHER STATES.
WE BASICALLY HAVE PEOPLE FROM
MARILYN.
FLYING TO CALIFORNIA TO TELL
CALIFORNIA'S CALIFORNIANS THAT
THEY SHOULD REGULATE IOWA.
THAT'S WHAT'S GOING ON HERE AND
THE REASON WHY THEY ARE NOT ON
BOARD WITH THE A. B. THIRTY
TWENTY ONE WHICH WE'D.
OPENLY OPPOSE WE'RE OPPOSED TO
IT WE THINK IT SHOULD BE CAGE
FREE NOW WE THINK THAT ONE
SQUARE FOOT PER HAND IS INSANELY
COOL.
BUT THE REASON WHY THEY ARE
DOING IT IS BECAUSE THE
LEGISLATION IS CLEAR.
THE LEGISLATION WHAT YOU SEE IS
WHAT YOU GET IT SAYS HERE'S
CAGES THEIR LEGAL UNTIL THIS DY.
CARES MUCH HOW MUCH SPACE YOU'RE
GOING TO GET.
THE REASON WHY EACH ISSUE S.
FEELS UNCOMFORTABLE.
UNDER.
THE ENDORSING THAT.
EVEN THOUGH THEY'RE ENDORSING
THE EXACT SAME POLICY THE EXACT
SAME KATE SIZE.
IN THE INITIATIVE.
IS THAT ANY INITIATIVE IT'S
BURIED IN A BUNCH OF OTHER
GARBAGE.
SO THEY DON'T HAVE TO ADMIT THAT
PROP TWO FAILED.
THEY CAN ACTED TODAY.
AT THIS GENTLEMAN HERE SAID WELL
THE REASON WHY WE DIDN'T --
SAY CAGE FREE EXPLICITLY
IMPROPER TO ONLY EVERY SINGLE
PIECE OF PROPAGANDA SAID IT THE
REASON WHY WE DIDN'T SAY IT IS
BECAUSE WE WANTED TO PHASE IT IN.
THAT IS COMPLETE DOUBLE TALK.
THAT'S COMPLETE DOUBLE TALK.
PROPOSITION TWO WAS A PHASE IN.
PROPOSITION TO A TWO THOUSAND
AND EIGHT SAID WE'RE GOING TO
GIVE THE EGG INDUSTRY SIX YEARS.
TO PROVIDE MORE ADVOCATES SPACE
AND EVENTUALLY IN THE YEAR TWO
THOUSAND AND FIFTEEN BE CAGE
FREE.
THAT IS A PHASE IN THAT IS A
PHASE IN THAT MANY ANIMAL
ORGANIZATIONS WERE NOT
COMFORTABLE WITH.
THEY THOUGHT SIX YEARS WAS TOO
LONG WE THOUGHT SIX YEARS WAS
TOO LONG.
HOWEVER WHEN SIX YEARS CAME
ALONG.
LO AND BEHOLD THE HANDS ARE
STILL IN CAGES.
H. AS YOU S. WAS TOLD PRIOR TO
SUBMITTING THEIR BAD THERE BUT
THEIR BALLOT MEASURE LANGUAGE
THAT EXACTLY THIS WAS GOING TO
TAKE PLACE.
BUT THEY SPEND THE LAST TEN
YEARS.
RAISING MONEY.
AND MAKING HEROES OUT OF THERE
NOW.
DISGRACED FORMER SEE EGO WHO IS
NOT HERE TO ANSWER VICTIM DO
REAL QUESTIONS.
CALIFORNIANS HAVE ABOUT THE
FRAUD THAT IS TAKING PLACE HERE.
HE'S NO LONGER IN THE PICTURE.
SO WE'VE GOT HAT THE NEW REGIME
COMING IN TRYING TO PICK UP THE
PIECES.
BUT THE OTHER THING THAT I WANT
TO TOUCH ON IS THE LEGISLATIVE
ANALYST'S WHEN YOU'RE LOOKING AT
THE COSTS.
THEY HAVEN'T YET FACTORED IN THE
COST [inaudible]
SENDING THIS PLAYING IN COURT
THE STATE OF CALIFORNIANS
ALREADY SPENT.
A TRUCKLOAD OF MONEY --
IS.
DEFENDING THE LAWS THAT ARE ON
THE BOOKS [inaudible]
THIS IS I HAM FISTED OVER REACH.
THAT IS ALREADY CAUSING
TREMENDOUS BLOW BACK BOTH IN
CONGRESS.
AND IN THE COURTS.
AND IN ALL LIKELIHOOD.
NONE OF THESE PROVISIONS FOR
THOSE CONCERNED ABOUT THE ROOM
THE RISING COSTS OF PORK DON'T
WORRY.
BECAUSE ULTIMATELY THIS IS GOING
TO BE RENDERED NULL AND VOID.
IT'S GONNA COME OFF AFTER A LOT
OF COSTS.
IT'S GOING TO CUT BY AFTER MANY
MILLIONS OF TAX DOLLARS IT'S
GOING TO COME AFTER A DOLLARS
FROM THE INDUSTRY THAT COULD
HAVE BEEN USED TO IMPROVE
CONDITIONS IT'S GONNA COME FROM
MONEY FROM THE HUMANE COMMUNITY.
THAT COULD BE USING THAT MONEY
TO ACTUALLY HELP ANIMALS.
IF EACH ISSUE S. REALLY KICK ALL
OF THE OTHER ARGUMENT AGAINST
THE LEGISLATION THAT TEACHERS U.
S. WILL SAY IS THAT WELL THE
LEGISLATION.
DOESN'T DO ANYTHING TO PROTECT
THOSE POOR CAPS IN CRATES WHO
CAN'T TURN AROUND.
IF H. AS U. S. CARED ABOUT CAPS
IN CRATES.
WHO CAN'T TURN AROUND THEY NEED
NOT GO NO FURTHER?
IN SOUTHERN CALIFORNIA.
WE HAVE COULD A CALF FARMS IN
CALIFORNIA WEIRD CAPS ARE
TETHERED IN CRATES.
VERY SIMILAR TO VEAL CRATES
WHERE THEY ARE UNABLE TO TURN
AROUND. EIGHT YEARS YOU S. HEADS
EXPLICITLY SAID NO THEY REFUSE
TO DO ANYTHING ABOUT.
CALIFORNIA ANIMALS.
INSTEAD THEY'RE SAYING.
WE'RE GOING TO LET THE CAPS IN
CALIFORNIA SCHEME CRATES BUT WE
WANT TO PASS AN INITIATIVE
THAT'S GOING TO TELL.
PENNSYLVANIA VEAL PRODUCERS THAT
YOU SHOULDN'T KEEP THEM IN
CRATES THERE OKAY HERE FOR
CALIFORNIA BUT WE'RE GOING TO
REGULATE YOU IN WISCONSIN.
AND THAT'S ABSURD.
THAT'S ABSOLUTELY ABSURD IT'S
DISINGENUOUS THEY KNOW THAT IS
IT ISN'T GOING TO FLY.
AND THE PROBLEM HERE IS NOT
SIMPLY THAT IT'S GOING TO BE
RENDERED NULL AND VOID.
THE PROBLEM IS THE DAMAGE THAT
IT'S GOING TO HAVE ON A WIDE
ARRAY OF OTHER CONSUMER.
ANIMAL.
ENVIRONMENTAL PROTECTION LAWS
BECAUSE WHEN THE COURTS AND
CONGRESS COME BACK AND WE GOT
THIS THING THEY'RE NOT GOING TO
USE A SCALPEL.
THEY'RE GOING TO USE A CANNON.
AND THAT CAN IN IS GOING TO
DESTROY A LOT OF LEGISLATION
THAT ALL OF US HAVE WORKED ON
OVER THE YEARS.
IT'S GOING TO DESTROY
LEGISLATION THAT FRANKLY IS
PROTECTING THE CALIFORNIA EGG
PRODUCERS IN SOME WAY IN IN MANY
WAYS ALL OF THAT'S GOING TO BE
RENDERED NULL AND VOID.
BECAUSE THEY ARE SO CONCERNED.
WE HAVE LOADING THIS UP WITH
DISTRACTIONS.
THIS IS A PUBLICITY STUNT IN
SEARCH OF A LAWSUIT.
AND FOR THEM THEY'RE LOOKING FOR
THE QUICK IMMEDIATE
GRATIFICATION THEY FEEL LIKE
ANYTHING THAT HAS THE WORD FARM
ANIMAL AND PROTECT.
IF IT HAS THOSE WORDS AND YOU
PUT IT ON THE BALLOT IT'S GOING
TO PASS.
AND PERHAPS THEY'RE RIGHT.
BUT THIS TIME AROUND.
IT'S GONNA FACE MAJOR OPPOSITION.
I DON'T SEE THE MAJOR OPPOSITION
COMING FROM.
WISCONSIN PORK PRODUCERS ARE OR
VIA PORTS PRODUCERS.
IT'S A HUMANE FARMING
ASSOCIATION.
ITS FRIENDS OF ANIMALS.
ITS PEOPLE FOR THE ETHICAL
TREATMENT OF ANIMALS IT SHOWING
ANIMALS RESPECT AND KINDNESS ITS
ACTION FOR ANIMALS IT'S OF THE
VAST MAJORITY OF RANK AND FILE
ANIMAL ACTIVE ADVOCATES THAT ARE
APPALLED BY THIS RUN NAY
INITIATIVE.
AND THAT'S WHY WE ARE WAGING
THIS.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH THANK YOU
VERY MUCH MISTER MILLER ANY
QUESTIONS THIS PANEL
[inaudible]
DRESSES MATHIS --
PERVERSE TO ONE EIGHT JOHN FOR
TAKING THE TIME I GOT TO RESPECT
THE MAN THAT'S GOT A LITTLE DUST
ON HIS BOOTS.
SO WHO'S ACTUALLY DOING IT --
MISTER MILLER A I THINK YOUR
POINTS ARE SPOT ON THE AYE AYE
SAID ON A LEGISLATIVE BOARD
DEALING WITH --
INTERSTATE AND FOR FOR
AGRICULTURAL.
ISSUES IN THE THE IDEA OF
CALIFORNIA MANDATING ANOTHER
STATE -- AND
MOST OTHER STATES MAN.
AND WOMEN AND OTHER STATES WOULD
FIND PREPOSTEROUS.
AND I THINK YOU'RE SPOT ON TO
SAY THAT WE'RE GONNA SPEND THE
MILLIONS UPON MILLIONS OF
DOLLARS ON YET ANOTHER LAWSUIT
CALIFORNIA FIGHTING.
PALM WHICH GOES INTO MY FATHER
CONCERN -- I
MENTIONED EARLIER.
IS IN THE IN AND WHAT'S NOT AND
THIS IS YOU KNOW WE WE TALK
ABOUT LAND USE.
AND THERE'S NOTHING IN THE
INITIATIVE PRESCRIBE BEING A
FASTER <c.green> I OUR PROCESS.</c>
TO CHANGE THE THE THE CAGE SIZE
HER A SEQUEL EXEMPTION AND HER
ANYTHING ALONG THOSE LINES --
AND QUITE FRANKLY IN THE STATE
OF CALIFORNIA TAKES OVER TWELVE
YEARS TO BUILD SUPER WALMART --
SO WE HAVE SOME ISSUES HERE SO
THEY THANK YOU JOHN THE FOR
INTERNET.
QUESTION ON THERE WAS CONCERNED
AFTER AWHILE FONG BUT THE UNIT
INTRODUCTION OF PROPOSITION TWO
THAT SOME OF THE ON EGG
PRODUCING BUSINESSES IN
CALIFORNIA WOULD LEAVE THE STATE.
ARE THERE ANY ESTIMATES OF AS TO
WHAT PERCENTAGE OF THE INDUSTRY
OR THE NUMBER OF FARMS ACTUALLY
LEFT THE STATE A NOTE THAT WAS
SAID EARLIER THAT.
WE LOST ABOUT A MILLION EGG
LAYING HENS QUITSCLOSER TO
SEVEN MILLION AND BUSINESSES ARE
ONLY A FEW SMALL ACTUALLY CLOSE
WHAT ENDED UP HAPPENING WAS THE
INDUSTRY ACTUALLY SHRUNK.
WE REDUCE START DENSITY BE THE
NUMBER OF HANDS WE WOULD HAVE
BEEN A BARN.
AND WITHOUT WE ALSO LOST THAT'S
THE SADDEST THING THAT HAPPENED.
THAT WE HAVE A SENSE OF WHAT
THAT PERCENTAGES IS IT 20%
TWENTY ROUGHLY ROUGHLY 19%
[inaudible]
THANK.
OF THE QUESTIONS.
BERMAN AT THANK YOU BOTH FOR
BEING HERE TODAY APPRECIATE THAT
I'M HEAR TESTIMONY AND I'M.
AS AS I SAID AT THE BEGINNING OF
THE HEARING --
OF WE DON'T TAKE ANY ACTION AT
THIS IS JUST AN INFORMATIONAL
HEARING BUT YOUR YOUR DATE IT'S
REALLY REALLY IMPORTANT I THINK
IT HITS RIGHT ON THE ISSUES WERE
CONCERNED ABOUT WHICH IS ON THE
IMPACT ON ON OUR FARMING
INDUSTRY AS WELL AS THE IMPACT
ON I THINK I THINK.
WE ALL WANT TO GO IN THERE IN
THE RIGHT DIRECTION --
BUT WE'VE GOT TO HAVE TIME TO BE
ABLE TO MAKE IT HAPPEN AND
ULTIMATELY IT'S IT'S OUR BY THE
PUBLIC THAT PAYS THE PRICE IT'S
OUR INDUSTRY GOING SO THANK YOU
BOTH VERY MUCH FOR BEING HERE
CRESCENTA VERY MUCH --
THAT THIS --
WE BRING IT AYE ONTO OUR PUBLIC
COMMENT PORTION OF THE OF THE
HEARING AND WE ONLY HAVE ONE
INDIVIDUAL THAT SIGNED UP SO IF
YOU WANTED TO SIGN UP THE NEED
TO SIGN UP WITH THE WITH THE
SERGEANT --
ASKING TO DO THAT A ERICA SANGHA
FROM THE CALIFORNIA PURPORT
PRODUCERS ASSOCIATION WELCOME
AND THANK YOU FOR BEING HERE.
ARE WE ON YES ERICA SANKO WITH
THE CALIFORNIA PORK PRODUCERS
ASSOCIATION APPRECIATE THE
OPPORTUNITY JUST TO PROVIDE SOME
SHORT COMMENTS.
WE ARE OPPOSED TO THE INITIATIVE
IN ITS ENTIRETY WE DO BELIEVE
THAT THOSE MAKING DECISIONS
REGARDING ANIMAL CARE AND
PRODUCTION PRACTICES SHOULD BE
MADE BY THOSE WHO HAVE THE
EXPERTISE AND KNOWLEDGE.
ARE FARMERS OR PRODUCERS NOT OUT
OF STATE ANIMAL ACTIVIST GROUPS
WITH A CERTAIN HIDDEN AGENDA.
THERE'S ACTUALLY NO SCIENTIFIC
JUSTIFICATION FOR THIS
INITIATIVE AND THERE'S NO
BENEFIT TO IT FOR CALIFORNIA OR
ITS CITIZENS IT WILL INCREASE
FOOD PRICES WITHOUT A DOUBT.
THE MAJORITY OF PORK PRODUCTS
THAT ARE IMPORTED INTO
CALIFORNIA WHERE THE MAJORITY OF
PORK PRODUCTS SOLD IN CALIFORNIA
ARE IMPORTED FROM STATES WHERE
PRODUCERS DO NOT HAVE TO COMPLY
WITH THIS LEGISLATION.
IOWA ILLINOIS AND A VARIETY OF
OTHER STATES.
AS A RESULT AS WE KNOW AND HAS
BEEN DISCUSSED ALREADY CHANGES
IN PRODUCTION PRACTICES COME AT
A SIGNIFICANT COST AND THOSE
WILL BE PASSED ON DIRECTLY TO
CONSUMERS.
THROUGH HIGHER RETAIL PRICES LOW
INCOME IN LOW INCOME HOUSEHOLDS
ARE ALREADY STRUGGLING WITH
HIGHER LIVING COSTS IN
CALIFORNIA.
THE ANSWER A FEW QUESTIONS VERY
QUICKLY THE UNIVERSITY OF
MINNESOTA STUDY IN TWO THOUSAND
FIFTEEN HAS SHOWN THAT RETAIL
EGG PRICES HERE IN CALIFORNIA
SINCE THE TWO THOUSAND FIFTEEN
LAW HAVE INCREASED SEVENTY
DOLLARS PER HOUSEHOLD.
A CORNELL STUDY.
IN TWO THOUSAND SIXTEEN AND
AGAIN IN TWO THOUSAND SEVENTEEN
HAS NOTED THAT FOR RETAIL PORT
PURCHASES CONSUMER SPEND TWO
POINT TWO MORE PER CAPITA IN
THEIR EXPENDITURES ON PORK.
SO IF YOU DO THE MATH THAT'S
OVER A HUNDRED AND SEVENTY
DOLLARS MORE PER HOUSEHOLD WILL
BE SPENDING ON PORK IF THIS
INITIATIVE PASSES.
IF IT IS A TAXPAYER FUNDED
PROGRAM SUCH AS WHERE OR SNAP OR
ANY INSTITUTIONAL FUNDING THOSE
COSTS WILL ALSO.
TRANSPIREIN THAT SO TO SAY
THERE ARE NOT ANY DIRECT IMPACTS
ON COST TO CONSUMERS IS
INCORRECT THERE WILL BE AND THAT
IS THE ISSUE.
AND FINALLY I WOULD LIKE TO SAY
THAT WE DO BELIEVE THE
CALIFORNIA PORK PRODUCERS DO
BELIEVE THAT WE WOULD HAVE SEEN
INCREASES AND GROWTH IN OUR
INDUSTRY IF IT WERE NOT FOR
THESE TYPE OF POLICIES
[inaudible]
THANK YOU.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
IS THERE ANYONE ELSE.
GOING ONCE GOING TWICE.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH FOR BEING
HERE TODAY REALLY APPRECIATE --
NEAR UP PARTICIPATION FOR ALL OF
YOU WHO TESTIFIED THANK YOU VERY
MUCH OF DOT CONCLUDES OUR
INFORMATIONAL HEARING AND WE
WILL -- TURN
THOUGH MIKE OVER --
TO AT SENATOR GALGIANI BECAUSE
SHE HAS A HEARING THAT SAID
FOLLOW SO THANK YOU VERY MUCH.